This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing evidence-based results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28. Newport treats clients who are struggling with mental health issues and co-occurring disorders, which are often triggered or intensified by the high levels of loneliness young people are experiencing right now. Newport's outpatient and residential programs around the country provide supportive, caring environments where adolescents and young adults can overcome isolation and build community. Learn more at newport healthcare.com. Even before the COVID-19 pandemic scrambled our social connections some two years ago, Americans were worried about an epidemic of loneliness. A pre-pandemic report from the National Academies of Sciences,
本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，该公司为12至28岁的青少年和年轻人提供基于证据、以结果为导向的治疗服务。Newport致力于帮助那些正在与心理健康问题及共病症作斗争的客户，这些问题往往是由年轻人目前所经历的高度孤独感所引发或加剧的。Newport在全国各地的门诊和住院项目提供支持性、关怀性的环境，让青少年和年轻人能够克服孤立感并建立社区联系。欲了解更多信息，请访问newporthealthcare.com。早在新冠疫情于两年前打乱我们的社交联系之前，美国人就已经在担忧一场孤独流行病了。美国国家科学院、
engineering and medicine, found that more than a third of people over age 45 reported in 2020 being lonely. One Kaiser Family Foundation poll in 2018 found that two and ten Americans often or always felt lonely. Researchers know that loneliness can be bad for our mental and physical health. We humans are social creatures and we need meaningful connections with other people in our lives. But are we lonelier than ever these days? Or are fears of a loneliness pandemic overblown. What's the difference between being alone and lonely? Can you be lonely even if your life is full of people? How exactly does loneliness affect our physical and mental health? Are some groups or types of people more at risk than others? And if you feel lonely or
工程院和医学院在疫情前的一份报告发现，2020年超过三分之一的45岁以上人群报告称自己感到孤独。凯撒家庭基金会2018年的一项民意调查发现，每十个美国人中就有两人经常或总是感到孤独。研究人员知道，孤独对我们的身心健康有害。我们人类是社会性动物，生活中需要与他人建立有意义的联系。但如今我们是否比以往任何时候都更孤独？或者说，对孤独流行病的恐惧是否被夸大了？独处和孤独之间有什么区别？即使生活在人群中，你也会感到孤独吗？孤独究竟如何影响我们的身心健康？某些群体或类型的人是否比其他人面临更大的风险？如果你感到孤独或
isolated or you're worried about someone else who does, what can you do to make a difference? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Louise Hawkeley, a psychologist and a principal research scientist at N-O-R-C, an independent research institution at the University of Chicago. She studies the effects of loneliness on health,
孤立，或者你担心身边有这样的人，你能做些什么来改善现状？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是路易丝·霍克利博士，她是一位心理学家，也是芝加哥大学独立研究机构NORC的首席研究科学家。她研究孤独对健康的影响，
the factors that increase the risk of loneliness, and the types of interventions that can help alleviate it. She collaborates with sociologists, physicians, epidemiologists, and others, to better understand the complexities of social life, especially as people age. Dr. Hawkeley has published more than 100 peer-reviewed articles and book chapters, and speaks often to the media on loneliness and social isolation. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Hawkeley. Thank you very much for having me.
以及增加孤独风险的因素，还有哪些类型的干预措施有助于缓解孤独。她与社会学家、医生、流行病学家等人合作，以更好地理解社会生活的复杂性，特别是在人们步入老年时。霍克利博士已经发表了100多篇同行评审文章和书籍章节，并经常就孤独和社会孤立问题向媒体发表见解。感谢您今天参加我的节目，霍克利博士。非常感谢您的邀请。
It's a delight to be part of this podcast. Thank you. Well, in your work, you talk about the difference between feeling lonely and being alone, or what researchers call social isolation. How are those two things different and how are they related? That's a very good opening question because it is often confused by people who talk about loneliness because they assume it means that you're alone. Whereas from our perspective, as researchers, we talk about loneliness as a feeling of being alone,
很高兴能参与这个播客。谢谢。在您的工作中，您谈到了感到孤独与独处（研究人员称之为社会孤立）之间的区别。这两者有何不同，又如何相关？这是一个非常好的开场问题，因为谈论孤独的人经常会混淆这两个概念，他们认为孤独意味着你是一个人。然而，从我们研究人员的角度来看，我们将孤独定义为一种孤独的感觉，
even though one doesn't have to be alone to feel that way. Social isolation is being alone or having infrequent interactions, feeling lonely is like feeling isolated regardless of the circumstances, and we've all been in that kind of circumstance where we are with people, but we don't feel connected to them. In other words, we feel lonely. Or we can be all alone and not feel lonely. So there is that disconnect. However, when you say, you know, how are they related? It is true on average that there is some degree of relationship. people who are more isolated have a greater risk of being somewhat lonelier than people who are less isolated. So I mentioned in the introduction that loneliness is bad for our physical and mental health.
即使一个人并不一定要独处才会有这种感觉。社会孤立是指独处或互动频率低，而感到孤独就像是在任何情况下都感到孤立，我们都经历过那种身处人群中却感觉与他们没有联系的情况。换句话说，我们感到孤独。或者我们也可以完全独处却不感到孤独。所以两者之间存在脱节。然而，当您问它们如何相关时，平均而言，它们确实存在一定程度的关联。更孤立的人比不那么孤立的人更有可能感到孤独。所以我在介绍中提到，孤独对我们的身心健康有害。
What kinds of health problems does loneliness cause and why is it harmful? Lots to say about both of those parts of the question. Certainly on an emotional mental health basis, there are pretty obvious correlates, you could say, but even causally. People who are lonely tend to be a greater risk for depression or at least become more depressive over time, like their symptoms of depression increase in number or severity, even if it doesn't reach the clinical threshold for depression. So there is that connection. There's also a relationship between loneliness and anxiety, certainly more generic feelings of well-being. and purpose and meaning in life are thwarted by feelings of loneliness.
孤独会导致哪些健康问题，为什么它是有害的？关于这个问题的两个方面有很多话要说。当然，在情感和心理健康方面，存在相当明显的关联，甚至可以说是因果关系。感到孤独的人往往面临更高的抑郁风险，或者至少随着时间的推移变得更加抑郁，即使他们的抑郁症状没有达到临床诊断标准，其数量或严重程度也会增加。所以存在这种联系。孤独与焦虑之间也存在关系，当然，更普遍的幸福感、生活目标和意义感也会受到孤独感的阻碍。
People tend not to feel as good about themselves in their lives when they're lonely. From the perspective of physical health, lots of, I'll call them consequences. Some of them have a pretty good evidentiary base that there's a really a direct causal relationship, but of course that's always difficult to determine when you're talking about loneliness, since you can't make people feel lonely and see what happens to their health. But it is the case that cardiovascular health in its many forms, whether it's heart problems, hypertension, stroke, those types of outcomes are more prevalent the lonelier people are.
当人们感到孤独时，往往对自己和生活的感觉不太好。从身体健康的角度来看，有很多后果。其中一些有相当好的证据基础，表明存在直接的因果关系，但当然，在谈论孤独时，这总是很难确定，因为你不能强迫人们感到孤独并观察他们的健康状况。但事实是，心血管健康在多种形式上，无论是心脏问题、高血压、中风，这些结果在越孤独的人群中越普遍。
That's a pretty robust association. There are also associations with other diseases of inflammation, which is the root of a lot of the chronic diseases of age, So there is some evidence for loneliness being associated with diabetes, certainly with cognitive decline and dementias, which is a very disturbing and real outcome of interest to a lot of older adults. There are also connections with sort of intermediary pathways, shall we say. So loneliness is related to increased risk for hypertension,
这是一种相当稳健的关联。它还与其他炎症性疾病有关，而炎症是许多慢性老年疾病的根源。因此，有一些证据表明孤独与糖尿病有关，当然也与认知能力下降和痴呆症有关，这是许多老年人非常担心且真实的后果。它还与所谓的中间途径有关。因此，孤独与高血压风险增加有关，
which is itself, sometimes a correlate of other diseases, but it's also a sign that there's something run amok with the inflammatory process in the body potentially. There are links with gene expression, which is an interesting and novel way of thinking about loneliness getting deep into our system and affecting the very proteins that are needed to maintain health and fight off disease. So in the case of lonely or older adults, they seem to be showing a greater upregulation, more activation of genes that are promoting inflammation rather than stanching inflammation. And likewise, they're showing underactivation of those genes that code for proteins that would diminish inflammation. So it's putting your foot on the gas and foot off the break
这本身有时是其他疾病的关联因素，但它也是体内炎症过程可能出现紊乱的信号。它与基因表达有关，这是一种思考孤独如何深入我们系统并影响维持健康和抵抗疾病所需蛋白质的有趣且新颖的方式。因此，在孤独的老年人中，他们似乎表现出更大的上调，即更多地激活了促进炎症而非抑制炎症的基因。同样，他们表现出那些编码减少炎症蛋白质的基因激活不足。所以这就像是踩下油门，同时松开刹车，
and all wheels forward we're going to go for the inflammation route. Well, that's a potential pathway then for a lot of the chronic diseases of aging. There are other relationships with lifestyle factors, you could say. So lonely people tend to be less active and to decline in their physical activity over time more so than people who are more connected. Their sleep is not as salubrious. So they might get the same amount of sleep, but they wake up tired. And some of the studies where we and others have used sensors to actually measure the kinds of sleep they're getting,
所有车轮都在向前推进，我们正走向炎症的道路。好吧，那这对于许多慢性老年疾病来说是一个潜在的途径。还有其他与生活方式因素相关的关系。所以孤独的人往往不太活跃，随着时间的推移，他们的身体活动水平比那些联系更紧密的人下降得更多。他们的睡眠质量也不太好。所以他们可能睡眠时间相同，但醒来时感到疲惫。在我们和其他人使用传感器来实际测量他们睡眠质量的研究中，
what seems to be interfered with is this continuity of sleep. People who are lonelier tend to see more disruption of their sleep. It's fragmented sleep. And sometimes it's not even fragmented to the point where they are aware that it's fragmented, but they're not staying in a deep sleep and they're losing out on the healthful stages of sleep. I should say that one of the biggest things that I think motivated a lot of interest in loneliness
似乎受到干扰的是睡眠的连续性。更孤独的人往往会经历更多的睡眠中断。这是碎片化的睡眠。有时甚至碎片化到他们自己都没有意识到，但他们没有保持深度睡眠，错过了睡眠中健康的部分。我应该说，我认为激发了人们对孤独和
and social isolation was the publication, well, it's actually to be in two, that looked at mortality differences between people who are more or less socially isolated or more or less lonely and found that there is a mortality difference where people who have good social relationships tend to live longer. People who are lonely, who are socially isolated, have an increased risk of premature mortality. So that got the ball rolling
社会孤立产生大量兴趣的最重要因素之一是两项研究的发表，它们观察了社会孤立程度高低或孤独感强弱的人群之间的死亡率差异，发现确实存在死亡率差异，拥有良好社会关系的人往往寿命更长。感到孤独、社会孤立的人过早死亡的风险增加。所以这开启了研究的序幕，
and thinking about, well, this is real. This is really doing something important in the body that we can't even live as long if we're lonelier. So it's fueled research in the area. What about social isolation? Is that also bad for people's health all by itself? So if someone doesn't have a lot of social connections, but they don't feel lonely, are they still at risk for the same kinds of physical and mental illnesses and conditions? I don't often study social isolation by itself, but we tend to look at it as an interactive factor. So people who are isolated and lonely are probably going to have worse. outcomes than those who are just isolated. But there are discrete impacts of different measures of social isolation. And this is where we get into some difficulty with how to even think about what social isolation is. So how do you measure it? What are you talking about? We can talk about people living alone. Is that by itself isolation? Is it bad for you? Maybe, maybe not. Maybe it
并开始思考，好吧，这是真实的。这确实在体内产生了一些重要的影响，以至于如果我们更孤独，甚至无法活得那么久。所以这推动了该领域的研究。那么社会孤立呢？它本身对人们的健康也有害吗？如果一个人没有太多的社会联系，但他们并不感到孤独，他们是否仍然面临同样的身体和心理疾病及状况的风险？我不常单独研究社会孤立，但我们倾向于将其视为一个交互因素。所以那些既孤立又孤独的人可能比仅仅孤立的人有更糟糕的结果。但社会孤立的不同衡量标准有其独特的具体影响。这就是我们在如何思考什么是社会孤立方面遇到困难的地方。那么你如何衡量它？你在谈论什么？我们可以谈论独居的人。这本身就是孤立吗？它对你有害吗？也许，也许不是。也许它
depends on whether you chose to live alone as opposed to here you are now with, you know, family has fled, spouses, died, you're living alone and perhaps have lost your social network. You're living alone and it feels quite different than the person who has decided they want to live alone and they have lots of social opportunities outside the house, whereas this first person hasn't got anything left to fill a social need. So when we talk about social isolation, we have to be careful about how we're talking about it, what we mean by isolation. And then, yes, there are discrete health impacts, but I think there is room for additional research there to understand under what conditions, under what type of isolation?
取决于你是选择独居，还是像现在这样，家人离散、配偶去世，你独自生活，可能失去了社交网络。你独自生活，这与那些决定独居且在屋外有大量社交机会的人感觉完全不同，而这第一个人已经没有任何东西来填补社交需求了。所以当我们谈论社会孤立时，我们必须小心我们谈论的方式，我们所说的孤立是什么意思。然后，是的，有具体的健康影响，但我认为在理解在什么条件下、什么类型的孤立下，还有进一步研究的空间。
What are we talking about when we say it has negative impacts? And it'll vary depending on how we think about and define social isolation. So how much do people vary in their need for social connection? For example, at one extreme, the Atlantic Magazine published a story recently about people who choose jobs where they work all night and sleep during the day because they say that they would rather have this life of isolation and darkness and that they're happy that way. So how much variation is there in our need for other people? Well, it's a good question. There is definitely variation. When I was working with John Cassiopo, we developed a model of loneliness and evolutionary theory.
当我们说它有负面影响时，我们在谈论什么？这取决于我们如何思考和定义社会孤立。那么人们对社会联系的需求差异有多大？例如，在一个极端，大西洋月刊最近发表了一篇关于人们选择整夜工作、白天睡觉的工作的故事，因为他们说他们宁愿过这种孤立和黑暗的生活，而且他们那样很开心。那么我们对他人需求的变化有多大？嗯，这是一个好问题。肯定存在差异。当我和约翰·卡乔波一起工作时，我们开发了一个孤独模型和进化理论，
based model where the foundation of any evolutionary theory is there has to be variation and there is reason for variation. And so the idea there with loneliness is that although we're all innately social, we have very different social needs and possibly for very good reasons. There are people think of hunter-gatherer days, people who would feel very comfortable leaving their socially safe surrounds their tribe, their community, to go look for food, to go fight off the enemy, and they could be gone for long periods of time and not feel the pain of social isolation. Others don't have that same freedom. They don't feel that they can safely leave.
任何进化理论的基础都是必须存在变异，并且存在变异的理由。因此，关于孤独的观点是，尽管我们天生具有社会性，但我们有非常不同的社会需求，而且可能是有充分理由的。有些人会想到狩猎采集时代，那些在离开社会安全环境、部落、社区去寻找食物、去抵御敌人时感到非常自在的人，他们可以离开很长时间而不感到社会孤立的痛苦。其他人没有同样的自由。他们不觉得他们可以安全地离开。
They're much more bound to their social community, and it's a need that differs for them as it does for still we have that variation in the population. The night owl story is an interesting one. And I think for some people, as you put it, they say they like it that way. But we have to be careful when we're relying on self-report because people can justify any life decision they make. And it may be that they've convinced themselves that they prefer it that way, but is it really good for them?
他们更受限于他们的社会社区，这是一种对他们来说与对其他人不同的需求，我们人口中仍然存在这种变异。夜猫子的故事很有趣。我认为对某些人来说，正如你所说，他们说他们喜欢那样。但当我们依赖自我报告时，我们必须小心，因为人们可以为他们做出的任何生活决定辩护。可能他们已经说服自己他们更喜欢那样，但这真的对他们有好处吗？
And this is where I think of how people say that, you know, they're sleeping fine in the city, despite traffic and sirens. Everything's fine. Their sleep is just great. But then you do a sleep study and you realize it's affecting them. It affects their sleep patterns, their sleep stages. It can give rise to increased heart rate, blood pressure, increased stress hormone, circulation. So we just have to be careful that we don't assume that people who say they prefer it
这就是我想到人们如何说，你知道，尽管有交通和警笛声，他们在城市里睡得很好。一切都很好。他们的睡眠非常好。但当你进行睡眠研究时，你会意识到这正在影响他们。它影响他们的睡眠模式、睡眠阶段。它会导致心率加快、血压升高、压力荷尔蒙循环增加。所以我们必须小心，不要假设那些说他们更喜欢它的人
are actually better off with what they say they prefer. And of course, you've turned your circadian rhythm upside down as well. You know, we evolved to sleep at night and be awake during the day. Yeah. So are some demographic groups more at risk for loneliness than others? For instance, are men more vulnerable than women? Yeah. I'd like to start that answer by reflecting on some research we did some years back,
实际上比他们所说的更喜欢的情况要好。当然，你也颠倒了你的昼夜节律。你知道，我们进化到晚上睡觉，白天清醒。是的。那么某些人口群体是否比其他人更容易受到孤独的影响？例如，男性是否比女性更脆弱？是的。我想通过回顾我们几年前做的一些研究来开始回答这个问题，
where we identified different dimensions or facets of the loneliness experience. So we found that loneliness has what we called an intimate connectedness component. That's sort of the opposite of loneliness and intimate connectedness, which was most closely related to or reflected in having a close romantic relationship, like having a spouse typically alleviated that need for an intimate connection. there was also a relational connectedness component that was diatic in the form of close friendships. Like, have you got a confidant? Are there, is there at least one person you can talk to outside of whatever spouse or partner you may have?
我们确定了孤独体验的不同维度或侧面。我们发现孤独具有我们所谓的亲密联系成分。那是孤独的反面，亲密联系，这与拥有亲密的浪漫关系最密切相关或反映在其中，比如拥有配偶通常会缓解对亲密联系的需求。还有一个关系联系成分，以亲密友谊的形式表现为二元关系。比如，你有知己吗？除了你可能拥有的任何配偶或伴侣之外，至少有一个你可以交谈的人吗？
Do you have confidants? And then there was a third component we identified as collective connectedness. And that reflects more the group sense of belonging, that you have some group of meaning to you where you feel you are of them. Those are your peeps, so to speak. And in the discussion about people who are at risk for loneliness, I think when you talk about a gender difference, you talk about a difference in vulnerability to certain types or forms of loneliness. Oftentimes, at least in married, heterosexual married partnerships, the woman is the social manager of the calendar. So she will create the contacts and create the opportunities for the husband to have a
你有知己吗？然后我们确定了第三个成分，即集体联系。这更多地反映了群体的归属感，即你拥有一些对你有意义的群体，在那里你感到你是他们的一员。用通俗的话说，那是你的伙伴。在讨论谁有孤独风险的人时，我认为当你谈论性别差异时，你谈论的是对某些类型或形式的孤独的脆弱性差异。通常，至少在已婚的异性恋伴侣中，女性是日程表的社交经理。所以她会创造联系并为丈夫创造机会，让他拥有一个
social life. So if she were to die, he suffers because he's lost that social manager. But in other ways, if that person, if that man has developed good group connections, whether it's, you know, pick up basketball or going to see the football game or play cards, if that connection, is still alive. That is how men tend to be more satisfied, shall we see? That kind of connection fills their need more so than it does for women, whereas women really rely more on the diatic connections, the confidants, the face-to-face, talk talk heart-to-heart about whatever is on your mind. So there are those kinds of differences and therefore differences in who's vulnerable to what. But if you think also of collective connectedness as this form of loneliness that has to do with feeling like you belong, then I think it helps one understand why a lot of peripheralized populations in the country are lonelier than others.
社交生活。所以如果她去世了，他会受苦，因为他失去了那个社交经理。但在其他方面，如果那个人，如果那个男人已经发展了良好的群体联系，无论是，你知道，打篮球还是去看足球比赛或打牌，如果那种联系仍然存在。这就是男性往往更满足的方式，我们可以说？那种联系比对女性更能满足他们的需求，而女性确实更依赖二元联系，知己，面对面，谈论你脑海中的任何事情。所以存在这些差异，因此在谁容易受到什么影响方面也存在差异。但如果你也把集体联系看作是这种与感觉自己属于某处有关的孤独形式，那么我认为这有助于人们理解为什么国内许多边缘化群体比其他人更孤独。
I think here of LGBT folks. They're on the periphery. Think of disabled people. You can even think about elderly because of ageism, they're kind of pushed to the side and they are some peripheral group that we will pay attention to when we have to, in whatever way, is expedient to us. And so they can be at higher risk. That said, it seems clear from research I and others have done over the last decade or so that contrary to popular opinion, older adults are not at highest risk of loneliness if you look at the whole age span. People who are in young adulthood tend to be even more at risk, tend to become lonelier. And although we have yet to have really good data to support this, we have some ideas to the kinds of things that might contribute. But one of the things that I think is going to
我在这里想到LGBT群体。他们处于边缘。想想残疾人。你甚至可以想到老年人，因为年龄歧视，他们被推到一边，他们是一些边缘群体，我们在必要时会关注他们，以任何对我们方便的方式。所以他们可能面临更高的风险。话虽如此，从我和其他人过去十年左右所做的研究来看，与大众观点相反，如果你看整个年龄跨度，老年人并不是孤独风险最高的。处于成年早期的人往往风险更高，往往变得更孤独。虽然我们还没有真正好的数据来支持这一点，但我们对可能导致这种情况的事情有一些想法。但我认为将
play a role in helping us understand that age difference in loneliness is that young adults are at a point in life where they're still looking for their niche. They're finding a career. They're finding a home. They're finding a partner if they're going to have one. They are subject to stereotypes, just as older adults, are subject to stereotypes. In their case, the stereotype is you're a young adult. You should be independently making your way through this world.
在帮助我们理解孤独的年龄差异方面发挥作用的一件事是，年轻人正处于人生的一个阶段，他们仍在寻找自己的定位。他们正在寻找职业。他们正在寻找家。如果他们要找伴侣，他们正在寻找伴侣。他们受到刻板印象的影响，就像老年人受到刻板印象的影响一样。在他们的情况下，刻板印象是你是一个年轻人。你应该独立地在这个世界上闯荡。
Well, anybody who's lived any length of time, I think, appreciates that you don't get through life independently. you get through life with the help of others. And it takes time for young adults to, at least in some cases, to find place in their view of life to think, I don't have to be totally responsible on my own for everything to be good. There is value to having a social safety net, if you want to call it that. It can be just for the companionship, the support. It doesn't have to be for anything terribly concrete, but knowing that others are there for you is really helpful to navigating that period of life. In older adulthood, the increase in loneliness really doesn't happen until oldest old age, meaning probably 80, 85 plus, because that's the age when people start losing a lot.
好吧，任何活过一段时间的人，我想，都会意识到你无法独立地度过一生。你是通过他人的帮助度过一生的。年轻人需要时间，至少在某些情况下，在他们的人生观中找到位置，去想，我不必对一切事情都完全负责才能过得好。拥有社会安全网是有价值的，如果你想这样称呼它的话。它可以只是为了陪伴、支持。它不必是为了任何非常具体的事情，但知道别人在那里支持你是对度过人生那个阶段非常有帮助的。在老年期，孤独感的增加实际上直到高龄才发生，意味着可能是80、85岁以上，因为那是人们开始失去很多东西的年龄。
They've lost a spouse. They've lost siblings. They may have even lost children, God forbid. They have lost health, ability. Maybe they've lost their independence and have to live in a care home of some kind. All of those losses are really stacking themselves, do stack themselves against the social well-being of an older adult. That's not as prevalent as we'd like to think it is.
他们失去了配偶。他们失去了兄弟姐妹。他们甚至可能失去了孩子，上帝保佑。他们失去了健康、能力。也许他们失去了独立性，不得不住在某种护理院。所有这些损失确实在堆积，确实在堆积，不利于老年人的社会福祉。这并不像我们想象的那样普遍。
There aren't that many people who we can write off as being in that category of having lost everything. So I think we have to be careful. When we talk about older adulthood, we're talking about this huge age range from 65 to 100. You know, that's 35 years. We would never lump together, you know, 15 to 50 year olds. That's another 35 year range because there's so much diversity. There's as much diversity in older adulthood. And so we have to be careful when we think about who's at risk and not just call it older adults. It is a. all older adults. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing accessible and ethical
没有那么多人我们可以将其归类为失去了一切。所以我认为我们必须小心。当我们谈论老年期时，我们谈论的是从65岁到100岁这个巨大的年龄范围。你知道，那是35年。我们永远不会把15岁到50岁的人归为一类。那是另一个35年的范围，因为多样性太多了。老年期的多样性也一样多。所以当我们思考谁有风险时，我们必须小心，不要仅仅称之为老年人。它是。所有老年人。本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，致力于提供无障碍和合乎道德的
treatment to young people ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with mental health conditions and behavioral issues. Newport's integrated whole-person approach addresses the underlying trauma, loneliness, and isolation that can lead to depression, anxiety, substance abuse, eating disorders, and other mental health issues. Newport offers a full continuum of care for teens and young adults with tailored treatment plans designed for each client's individual needs and history. At Newport's residential and outpatient locations around the country, teens and young adults learn self-knowledge and healthy coping skills
治疗，帮助12至28岁正在与心理健康状况和行为问题作斗争的年轻人。Newport的综合全人方法解决了可能导致抑郁、焦虑、药物滥用、饮食失调和其他心理健康问题的潜在创伤、孤独和孤立。Newport为青少年和年轻人提供完整的护理连续体，并为每个客户的个人需求和历史量身定制治疗计划。在Newport全国各地的住院和门诊地点，青少年和年轻人学习自我认知和健康的应对技能，
while building caring connections with peers and mentors. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. We are living in an aging population here in the, U.S. and is this something that concerns you a lot as baby boomers are, you know, we're hitting those numbers up there, we're getting old. Yes, yes. Yeah, there will be more older adults, definitely. And so one would think, even if all else is equal, we'll have more people who are suffering from loneliness and isolation. The work we've done recently, both with American data and with UK data, where we compared two generations, the baby boomer, generation and the silent generation. We were looking at whether if we compared them at the same
同时与同龄人和导师建立关怀联系。欲了解更多信息，请访问newporthealthcare.com。我们生活在美国一个老龄化的人口中，随着婴儿潮一代，你知道，我们正在达到那些数字，我们正在变老，这是让你非常担心的事情吗？是的，是的。是的，会有更多的老年人，肯定的。所以人们会认为，即使其他一切都相同，我们也会有更多的人遭受孤独和孤立。我们最近所做的工作，无论是使用美国数据还是英国数据，我们比较了两代人，婴儿潮一代和沉默的一代。我们正在观察如果我们比较他们在相同
age were baby boomers at 60 years of age any lonelier than the silent generation when they were 60 years old, no evidence for that in either country. In fact, there's some evidence that suggests that baby boomers are perhaps at an advantage. They may be less lonely than the earlier generation. Hard to say yet what that will be attributable to, but one can imagine that with this latest generation, there's a lot more autonomy, self-directed push toward getting their needs met, whereas the silent generation was perhaps more subject to the stereotypes and the expectations of a life that is no longer, you know, possible for them. Family isn't there to support them like they might have thought it was going to be. Baby boomers are much less likely to rely solely
年龄时，60岁的婴儿潮一代是否比60岁时的沉默一代更孤独，在这两个国家都没有证据支持这一点。事实上，有一些证据表明婴儿潮一代可能处于优势。他们可能比前一代人更不孤独。很难说这归因于什么，但人们可以想象，对于这一代人来说，有更多的自主权，更多地推动满足自己的需求，而沉默的一代可能更多地受到刻板印象和对不再可能的生活的期望的束缚。家庭不像他们可能认为的那样在那里支持他们。婴儿潮一代不太可能仅仅依赖
on nuclear family. They've developed a broader network. They've moved around and have a lot of different people and structures that are helping to support their aging. So they may be in a better position remains to be seen. So I was looking at some numbers related to loneliness and isolation. and it seems like there are now something like 36 million single person households in the U.S. that the marriage rate has been steadily dropping since the 1950s, and the proportion of Americans who have never married is now higher than it has ever been. I think it's about 35 percent now. We're becoming a nation of loners.
核心家庭。他们发展了更广泛的网络。他们搬迁了，有许多不同的人和结构来帮助支持他们的老龄化。所以他们可能处于更好的位置，还有待观察。所以我正在查看一些与孤独和孤立相关的数字。似乎现在美国有大约3600万单人家庭，结婚率自1950年代以来一直在稳步下降，从未结婚的美国人比例现在比以往任何时候都高。我想现在大约是35%。我们正在成为一个孤独者的国家。
It seems that way, doesn't it? Those kinds of numbers certainly look that way. it does make me wonder what the downstream consequences are going to be long-term consequences. I don't know. I think it really is going to depend a lot on whether this being alone is accompanied by what LGBT folks call families of choice. I mean, it's just getting people around you that need not be a spouse in a traditional, you know, two-child family or whatever it might have been in the past. but it is some way of connecting themselves to a community. Community is another key word in thinking about loneliness. So we'll see what all this lone living means.
看起来是这样，不是吗？这些数字看起来确实如此。这确实让我怀疑长期的后果会是什么。我不知道。我认为这真的很大程度上取决于这种独处是否伴随着LGBT群体所说的选择家庭。我的意思是，这只是让需要你的人围绕在你身边，而不必是传统意义上的配偶，你知道，两个孩子的家庭或过去可能有的任何情况。但这是将他们自己与社区联系起来的某种方式。社区是思考孤独的另一个关键词。所以我们将看看所有这些独居意味着什么。
Eric Kleinenberg's book on Living Alone, he interviewed a lot of people who chose to live alone, and the argument there was that it's not necessarily a bad thing. So I think it really depends on what people do with their. their aloneness. And I think there's also a growing trend toward communities where you can age in place and people coming together so younger people will support the older people in the community, making sure that they get their groceries, they go to the doctor's appointment, that they're safe.
埃里克·克莱南伯格关于独居的书，他采访了许多选择独居的人，他的论点是这不一定是一件坏事。所以我认为这真的取决于人们如何处理他们的独处。而且我认为也有一种日益增长的趋势，即人们可以原地养老的社区，人们聚在一起，这样年轻人会支持社区里的老年人，确保他们买到杂货，去看医生，确保他们是安全的。
And perhaps we boomers will be protected from being completely isolated as we age, if we age in place. Yeah, that intergenerational component is, I think, really important because it tackles ageism at the same time where you dissolve the stereotypes that young have about old and old have about young. Having these kinds of aging in place communities cuts both ways. It isn't just the young people helping the older people. It's the older people taking care of the kids while mom is out having to do an errand. So it's a mutually beneficial arrangement or it can be. And I think that's something we should be training our eyes and minds toward. So what kind of advice would you give to people who are feeling
也许我们婴儿潮一代在变老时会受到保护，免于完全孤立，如果我们原地养老的话。是的，那种代际成分，我认为，非常重要，因为它同时解决了年龄歧视，消除了年轻人对老年人以及老年人对年轻人持有的刻板印象。拥有这种原地养老的社区是双向的。不仅仅是年轻人帮助老年人。当妈妈出去办事时，老年人也在照顾孩子。所以这是一种互惠互利的安排，或者可以是。我认为这是我们应该训练我们的眼睛和思想去关注的事情。那么你会给那些感到
lonely, not isolated, but they really feel lonely. Like, where do you start in identifying the causes of your loneliness and then what do you do to mitigate it? Yeah, that's a lots of things that could be offered there. I think if it's a case of realizing that you are lonely in spite of your social circumstances, that is, you have people around you, but you're not feeling it, you're not feeling connected. It may be a matter of learning to identify the types of people, the groups where you might feel more at home. To take a stark example, if you're a bookworm, don't go to a dance bar to find somebody to talk to. I mean, looks for like for this purpose. You want to find a connection with people who are like you. But there are difficulties that people have once they've been lonely,
孤独的人什么建议，不是孤立，而是他们真的感到孤独。比如，你从哪里开始识别你孤独的原因，然后你做什么来缓解它？是的，那里可以提供很多东西。我认为如果是因为意识到尽管你的社会环境很好，你仍然感到孤独，也就是说，你身边有人，但你没有感觉到，你没有感觉到联系。这可能是一个学习识别你可能感到更自在的人群、群体的问题。举一个鲜明的例子，如果你是一个书虫，不要去舞厅找人交谈。我的意思是，寻找志同道合的人。但人们一旦孤独，就会遇到困难，
for some time, and this is part of our evolutionary theory or model, where it's a spiral. You feel lonely, and there is a kind of a knee-jerk reaction to that, where you consider yourself possibly not likable, so you start feeling a little defensive, maybe a little anxious, that people are looking for the negative stuff in you, and you don't want them to see that, so you tend to withdraw so that they don't see that, but that, of course, means you're not opening yourself up to the positive things either. And those expectations that people might not be nice toward you tend to be reinforced. It's a self-fulfilling prophecy. If you're expecting to see the negative stuff, you're going to see the negative stuff. And so you will maybe have less
有一段时间，这是我们进化理论或模型的一部分，这是一个螺旋。你感到孤独，对此有一种膝跳反应，你认为自己可能不可爱，所以你开始感到有点防御，也许有点焦虑，人们在寻找你的负面东西，你不想让他们看到，所以你倾向于退缩，这样他们就不会看到，但这当然意味着你也没有向积极的东西敞开自己。而那些人们可能对你不友好的期望往往会得到加强。这是一个自我实现的预言。如果你期待看到负面的东西，你就会看到负面的东西。所以你可能会有更少的
quality in your interactions, and that's really important for feelings of loneliness. You want to have, if you want to get over those feelings, you want a good quality, not just a superficial interaction. So you want to recognize that that's happening, that your brain is being hijacked essentially and making you think things are perhaps not the way they really are. So reality check. Maybe the person that didn't talk to me at the grocery checkout had a bad morning, just had an accident and just couldn't talk. And so it's not me, it's them. So learning to reattribute the causes of your loneliness can be helpful. There are instances where I think it's worthwhile talking with a professional. There can be difficulties surmounting these thinking
互动质量，这对孤独感非常重要。如果你想克服那些感觉，你想要高质量的，不仅仅是肤浅的互动。所以你想认识到正在发生的事情，你的大脑本质上被劫持了，让你认为事情可能不像它们真正的那样。所以现实检查。也许在杂货店结账时没有和我说话的人度过了一个糟糕的早晨，刚刚发生了事故，只是无法说话。所以这不是我，是他们。所以学习重新归因你孤独的原因会有所帮助。在某些情况下，我认为与专业人士交谈是值得的。克服这些思维可能会有困难
problems, if you want to call them that, where we get caught up in cycles of thought that perpetuate the loneliness rather than get us out of it. But I also want to make sure that people appreciate that this isn't all the problem of the lonely person. They're not the victim here. They're not solely responsible. We live in a society that pushes people to the edge if they don't match exactly what we want. And there has to be a place for society to appreciate for communities at the community level or neighborhood level, to appreciate diversity that we all belong. We all have a place. And how can we ensure that?
问题，如果你想这样称呼它们的话，我们陷入了使孤独永久化而不是让我们摆脱它的思维循环中。但我也想确保人们意识到这并不全是孤独者的问题。他们不是这里的受害者。他们不负全部责任。我们生活在一个如果人们不完全符合我们想要的，就会把他们推向边缘的社会。社会必须有一个地方，在社区层面或邻里层面，去欣赏多样性，我们都属于这里。我们都有一个位置。我们如何确保这一点？
How can we make space for everyone to offer what they have to offer to the group and make them feel like they belong? And I don't say this in a make them forceful kind of way, but create a space that is safe and open and receptive to all comers. So there's been a lot of headlines in the past two years about whether the social distancing precautions and isolation that a lot of us have taken during the COVID pandemic have caused a secondary loneliness pandemic. Do you think that's happened or is that overblown? Is that just the media latching onto a convenient term? It's a good point there because I think the media does capitalize on, I'll call it the sensationalistic news, that it is possibly overblown.
我们如何为每个人腾出空间，让他们提供他们所能提供的给群体，让他们感到他们属于这里？我不是以一种强迫的方式说这个，而是创造一个安全、开放和接受所有来者的空间。所以过去两年里有很多关于我们在新冠疫情期间采取的社交距离预防措施和孤立是否导致了二次孤独流行病的头条新闻。你认为这发生了吗，还是被夸大了？这只是媒体抓住了一个方便的术语吗？这是一个很好的观点，因为我认为媒体确实利用了，我会称之为耸人听闻的新闻，它可能被夸大了。
But I think the jury's still out. I think the long-term consequences of the pandemic on things like loneliness have yet to be seen. I think we saw a little bit of the unexpected, even when the pandemic started, in that the data indicated an initial, very brief spike in loneliness that quickly almost normalized. But then what about the long haul? when we're not interacting in the fashion that we've been accustomed to, is there a slow drag on our sense of social fit, social connection? And does that take a longer term toll on how we feel about our social lives? I think that's still up for more research, frankly. So we don't really know yet than whether some of these remote connections, Zoom and so forth, are replacing those in-person
但我认为陪审团还没有定论。我认为疫情对孤独等事情的长期后果还有待观察。我认为我们甚至在疫情开始时就看到了一些意想不到的事情，数据表明孤独感出现了短暂的、非常短暂的激增，很快几乎正常化了。但长远来看呢？当我们没有按照我们习惯的方式互动时，我们的社会适应感、社会联系感是否会受到缓慢的拖累？这是否会对我们对社交生活的感受产生更长期的影响？坦率地说，我认为这仍然需要更多的研究。所以我们还不知道这些远程联系，Zoom等等，是否正在取代那些面对面
interactions. Well, the study that I did, which was done about six to eight months into the pandemic from September of 20 through January of 2021, this was using data from the National Social Life, Health and Aging Project. We specifically asked older adults, how have you changed, how you are interacting with family and with friends during this time. And have you increased, decreased, or stayed the same and how often you have in-person interactions? How about by phone? How about by messaging, whether it's email or text or social media? What about video calls? And although we saw some small percentage of
互动。嗯，我做的研究，是在疫情开始六到八个月后，从20年9月到21年1月进行的，这是使用来自国家社会生活、健康和老龄化项目的数据。我们专门问老年人，在这段时间里，你如何改变了你与家人和朋友互动的方式。你增加了、减少了还是保持了你面对面互动的频率？电话呢？消息呢，无论是电子邮件、短信还是社交媒体？视频通话呢？虽然我们看到一小部分
older adults actually increase their use of these remote technologies, when it came time to looking at how lonely they felt, it didn't matter how much they used that technology. The fact that they decreased their in-person interaction frequency was not compensated by these increased remote technology uses. However, having said that, we don't yet know what is an adequate dose. It's not to say that the remote types of social interaction aren't useful at all, but we don't know how much is required, when, for how often, and we didn't have a big percentage of the population who showed an increase. Why is that? We have to look at even basic things like broadband access. Could they have used video calling? What about just their ability to use?
老年人实际上增加了他们对这些远程技术的使用，当谈到观察他们感到多孤独时，他们使用多少技术并不重要。他们减少面对面互动频率的事实并没有被这些增加的远程技术使用所补偿。然而，话虽如此，我们还不知道什么是足够的剂量。并不是说远程类型的社交互动一点用都没有，但我们不知道需要多少，什么时候，多久一次，而且我们没有很大比例的人口表现出增加。为什么会这样？我们必须看看即使是像宽带接入这样的基本事情。他们能使用视频通话吗？他们使用
devices or knowledge in how to access the internet, even if they have it. So there are those hurdles that have to be gotten over. And I think we've made a step in the direction toward older adults becoming more facile in that way, if for no other reason that a lot of the health-related deliveries are now by remote means. And so I think there's more attention being paid, people getting familiar with this technology and use. it. How at the same time, I'd also say it's never going to replace in person. And we know that from other research, even in younger people, where it's not a substitute. It's a nice supplement. It's nice in addition to in person, but it does not compensate for the richness of a visual, oral,
设备的能力或即使他们有互联网，他们知道如何访问互联网的能力又如何呢？所以这些障碍必须被克服。而且我认为我们已经朝着老年人变得更灵活的方向迈出了一步，如果仅仅是因为许多与健康相关的交付现在都是通过远程方式进行的。所以我认为人们更加关注，人们熟悉这种技术并使用它。同时，我也想说它永远不会取代面对面。我们从其他研究中知道这一点，即使在年轻人中，它也不是替代品。它是一个很好的补充。它在面对面之外很好，但它不能补偿视觉、口头的丰富性，
smell, taste, touch, interaction with a human being. There's some people I'd rather not smell, but okay. Got it. So what's next for you? What are you looking at now? I mean, there has to be just, there's so many questions I'm sure related to the pandemic and the isolation that we've been living through. For my personal work right now, I'm heading more in the direction of what can we do about
嗅觉、味觉、触觉，以及与人的互动。有些人我宁愿不去闻，但好吧，我明白了。那么你接下来的计划是什么？你现在在关注什么？我的意思是，肯定有太多与疫情以及我们所经历的隔离相关的问题。就我目前个人的工作而言，我正朝着我们能做些什么的方向努力
it from policy level on down. So what my work, for example, with the Illinois Aging Services is to understand. what it is they've been doing and tried to do during the pandemic to help older adults maintain some social connection. And we're just doing an evaluation. Here we have a population that was targeted by Governor Pritzker's budget. We need to help older adults avoid or get over social isolation. And through the area agencies on aging, programming has been rolled out.
从政策层面及以下层面来解决这个问题。例如，我与伊利诺伊州老龄服务部门合作的工作是去了解他们在疫情期间为了帮助老年人保持某种社会联系所做和尝试做的事情。我们正在进行评估。这里有一个受普利兹克州长预算支持的群体。我们需要帮助老年人避免或克服社会孤立。通过老龄化区域机构，相关项目已经展开。
Is it effective? If we learn anything from these kinds of attempts, we want to make sure that there's evidence that makes these particular interventions scalable. We want to disseminate these. We don't want to reinvent the wheel everywhere we go for how we're going to deal with this. And certainly the pandemic was primetime. People out of desperation or the visions of dollar signs came up with all kinds of ideas for what they could do to alleviate loneliness and isolation. Some will work, some won't. We need the data. And then scale that. Also doing work with the AARP Foundation, we developed an interactive map for them where you can see how social isolation overlaps with other risk factors at a county level in the state. So if you look at something like
它有效吗？如果我们能从这些尝试中吸取任何教训，我们希望确保有证据证明这些特定的干预措施是可以推广的。我们希望推广这些经验。我们不想在处理这个问题时到处重复造轮子。当然，疫情是一个关键时期。人们出于绝望或对金钱的渴望，想出了各种各样的点子来缓解孤独和孤立。有些会奏效，有些则不会。我们需要数据，然后进行推广。此外，在与美国退休人员协会（AARP）基金会的合作中，我们为他们开发了一张交互式地图，你可以从中看到在州县一级，社会孤立是如何与其他风险因素重叠的。所以如果你看看类似
broadband access, it's pretty clear there's an inverse association between broadband access and social isolation. If you have broadband access, you're in a county that has lower prevalence of social isolation in older adults. And there are other variables that one can look at at this map, but the point of the map is to identify where are these high-risk counties? What distinguishes them from other counties, and then what can we do about it? Well, Dr. Hockley, this has been really interesting. I very much appreciate your taking the time to speak with us today. Thank you.
宽带接入，很明显宽带接入与社会孤立之间存在负相关关系。如果你有宽带接入，你所在的县老年人社会孤立的发生率就较低。这张地图上还有其他变量可以查看，但地图的重点是确定这些高风险县在哪里？它们与其他县有什么区别，然后我们能做些什么？好的，霍克利博士，这真的非常有趣。非常感谢你今天抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢。
Thank you. It was a pleasure to have this conversation. Important topic. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spinkingof Psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening to us on Apple, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us, at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org.
谢谢。很高兴能进行这次谈话。这是一个重要的话题。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你是在苹果平台上收听我们的节目，请留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。